un barco de apoyo perteneciente a
Naciones Unidas navega por el mar rojo
con una misión iniciar lo más pronto
posible el operativo de salvamiento del
fs o seifer una embarcación de
almacenamiento petrolero que posee más
de un millón de barriles de crudo y que
se ha convertido en una bomba
medioambiental tras quedar varado en
durante el año pasado tuvimos varias
reuniones y discusiones con las Naciones
Unidas hubo avances y retrasos a veces
pero Hemos llegado a esto hoy que es la
culminación del trabajo en el período
pasado
le salió el seifer está anclado en el
mar rojo desde 1987 frente al puerto
Rebelde de odeira una de las principales
puertas de entrada para la ayuda
humanitaria del país desde el estallido
del conflicto yemení en 2014 el barco
petrolero quedó abandonado sin recibir
mantenimiento el agua ha deteriorado la
estructura generando peligros de
explosión y un accidente medioambiental
sin precedentes el programa de las
Naciones Unidas para el desarrollo
advirtió que un derrame afectaría
200.000 medios de subsistencia y
comunidades enteras que darían expuesta
toxinas
creo que esta combinación Nos ha
funcionado muy bien para encontrar una
salida a un problema que ha estado aquí
durante ocho años la gente ha estado
hablando de ello pero sin hacer nada al
respecto este grupo ha podido hacer algo
al respecto creo que tendremos éxito
la ONU estima que la operación comenzará
en 10 días y demorará meses sostienen
que la cantidad de petróleo es cuatro
veces más grande que el derrame de
Alaska en 1989 una de las mayores
catástrofes de este tipo